You're going to learn how to say I
don't know the right way and maintain
your credibility in the process.
So here's a situation
I've seen numerous times.
A professional shares some important
information at a group meeting.
or someone is in a public
speaking situation.
All is going well so far, but once
the question and answer period
starts, somebody asks a question
and the speaker doesn't know
the answer and they fall apart.
They look like a deer stunned
in the headlights of a car.
They act like they've been caught
and they are very hesitant to
say the words, I don't know.
But sometimes that's
exactly what you should say.
Saying I don't know is always better
than faking it and attempting to
BS your way through the answer.
If you try to make something up or
swerve around the answer, people
will notice and it'll almost
always cost you some credibility.
But don't worry, I'm going to show
you exactly how to say, I don't know.
And you're going to be so smooth
by the end of this video, nobody
will even notice you didn't know.
I first learned these basic tips
that we'll share when I worked for
a longtime mentor, Allen Weiner.
I've mentioned him in a lot of videos.
He's the author of So Smart But how
intelligent people lose credibility
and how they can get it back.
We're going to use the
slice method in this video.
The first slice is for beginners, the
second slice is an intermediate version,
and the third slice is for advanced
application and it is smooth as silk.
Slice 1 is the biggest slice in the video.
When you don't know the answer
to a question, especially in that
group situation, there are three
acceptable ways to say I don't know.
One perfectly acceptable answer that will
help you maintain your credibility is to
say some version of, I don't know, but
I will look into it and get back to you.
Or, I don't know, but I'll
find out and follow up.
I've seen this done a thousand times
from really confident speakers.
That's how they do it.
Now, the key with all of these is that
you have to maintain your composure.
Don't hesitate or act embarrassed.
So, if somebody asks you a question
and you don't know the answer, but
perhaps you should know the answer
based upon your role, you just pause,
think for a moment, and then simply
reply with some version of, I don't
know, or I'm not sure, but I'll look
into it and come back to you shortly.
We're still talking about Slice1,
and the next way to say, I don't
know, is to then refer them to
somebody who does know the answer.
There are many situations where somebody
may ask you a question that is genuinely
outside of the scope of your job or
outside of the realm of information that
you just delivered in your presentation.
You're not expected to know everything
just because they're asking you, but
if there's someone around that you
could refer them to, that's the expert
who you want to point them towards.
And it sounds like this, I don't know,
but Gary should have that information.
Or I don't know, but I would refer you
to Gary who works in that department.
A couple of points of
clarification about this one.
You want to be sure the person you
are mentioning really does know
the answer, or at least they should
know the answer better than you.
Do your best to identify the right
person for the job, in other words.
And if the person is in the room
at the time, that's fantastic.
Now, on the one hand, they can answer
the question right there and then.
On the other hand, make sure
you don't throw them under the
bus or blame them for anything.
So refer to them in a supportive
and in a conversational way.
If somebody asks you a question and
you believe that Gary might be the
right person to answer it, you would
say respectfully, Is Gary here?
Gary, would you like to
answer that question?
And the third way to say I don't
know and maintain credibility is
to tell them what you do know.
I learned this tip from an old
consultant friend of mine, Joe Jokowicz.
So thank you, Joe.
There are many occasions where you'll
be asked a question that is slightly
off focus or may reflect the other
person's agenda a little too much.
Their question may not be as relevant as
they're making it sound in the moment.
In other instances, they may be asking
you for data or information that
simply doesn't exist or doesn't exist
yet or you don't have access to it.
In situations like this, you would
say, I don't know, but here's what I
do know, or here's what I can tell you.
And then you give them the best
information that you have, that at
least somewhat addresses their concern.
So let's say, for example, somebody
asks you about the exact sales figures
for the quarter that just closed, and
you don't know the answer to that.
You might say, I don't know the exact
numbers, but I have heard it was
our strongest quarter in two years.
If someone asks, how many
people were there last night?
You could say, I don't know how many,
but I can tell you it was packed
and there was a line out the door.
You notice in my examples, I'm not trying
to be argumentative or change the subject.
I'm not trying to dodge the question.
I just don't know the exact answer.
So I try to give them something
that's valuable that corresponds to
their underlying concern or question.
That's when you use this option.
I don't know, but here's what I do
know, or here's what I can tell you.
So far, that was all Slice 1,
the biggest slice of the video.
Now let's move on to Slice 2, which
is an intermediate way to answer.
Use this approach if you simply want
to avoid saying the actual words
quote I don't know for some reason.
Maybe you don't like how it sounds
or at least you don't want to
say it repetitively if people
ask you multiple questions.
If that's the case, there are lots of
other ways to say that that sound a
little better, but are still honest.
Here are some other ways to say it.
I haven't seen any data about that yet.
Or, I can't be certain because
and then fill in the reason.
Or, We'll have that answer by and
then give them a time estimate.
I'd have to confirm
before I comment on that.
I don't have that answer right
now, but And then you would give
them whatever answer you did have.
In fact, I'll bet as you're watching
this right now, you've probably heard
other ways to say, I don't know,
that sound pretty good to your ears.
So I have a request.
Do all future viewers a favor of
this video and suggest an alternative
wording that sounds good to you
without saying, I don't know,
sounds supportive, it sounds honest.
Put your suggestions in the
comments below for everybody to see.
Now here's what to do with
these alternative phrases.
If you have an upcoming presentation or
group meeting and you anticipate some
Q& A and you may not know the answer,
practice a few of these alternative
ways to say I don't know aloud.
Have them in your back pocket.
Now I recommend practicing them out
loud so they sound fluent and confident
coming out of your mouth in the moment.
Slice 2 is a little more advanced
than Slice 1 because you don't
directly say I don't know, but you're
still being honest and truthful.
Using different language may help you
save face a little bit in the moment
and project confidence as you answer.
And you can follow up any of those phrases
again by saying, I'll follow up with you.
Refer them to somebody else who does
know or tell them what you do know.
And now for Slice 3.
This is a little more advanced, but you
can use this advice fairly quickly with a
few minutes of practice on Slice 1 and 2.
And here's the tip for helping
you sound as smooth as silk.
Skip over the part of the sentence
that says, I don't know, altogether.
and just say the second
part of your answer.
Here's some earlier examples and we're
just going to leave off the statement
I don't know and say the second part.
You'll see that with some minor
adjustments in your wording, this will
still work great in most situations.
I'll have to look into that
information and get back to you.
I'll find you that answer and follow up.
Gary should have that information.
I would refer you to Gary
who works in that department.
If Gary is here, he's the
best person to answer that.
I know that it was our
strongest quarter in two years.
I can tell you it was packed and
there was a line out the door.
And the reason this approach works
is that you are still doing your
best to help the other person.
It's not a dodge.
We may not know the answer, but
we're still trying to provide an
answer that will give them some
helpful information or at least
point them in the right direction.
So, even though this entire video
is about how to say I don't know and
maintain credibility, there are ways to
give an honest answer without having to
always say the actual words every time.
I cannot emphasize enough that even though
we're really talking about just the words
you say in this video, your conversational
tone, your positive and professional
attitude will go a long way to projecting
confidence and credibility regardless
of which of these three slices you use.
As you practice this on your own, be
sure to combine the right words with
the right attitude, in other words.
Until next time, thanks, God
bless, and I'll see you soon.